turning to the midterms where there is a
new twist in the pivotal Senate race in
Georgia the website The Daily Beast is
reporting Republican candidate Herschel
Walker paid for a woman he was dating to
get an abortion in 2009 he strongly
denies it in his campaign for Senate the
former football star says he's staunchly
anti-abortion this comes as polish show
Walker in a close race against
Democratic senator Raphael Warnock with
13 percent undecided Nicole Killian is
following all of this Nicole good
morning good morning to you Nate
Herschel Walker son posted a scathing
reaction after this story broke meantime
Herschel Walker says he plans to sue the
media outlet that wrote the story and
called it a defamatory lie
and right now I'm for life and I'm not
going to make an excuse for it Georgia
Republican Senate candidate Herschel
Walker says he is pro-life and supports
a nationwide abortion ban with no
exceptions I believe in life yes and
there's no excuses
I believe in life I you know I don't
think I want to go into what it includes
because who knows but new reporting from
The Daily Beast which has not been
independently confirmed by CBS News
claims he encouraged a woman he was
dating in 2009 to get an abortion and
help pay for it the woman whose identity
was not published provided The Daily
Beast with a receipt for the procedure a
get well card and an image of a 700
check allegedly signed by Walker it is a
flat out lie Walker denied the
allegations on Fox News Monday night but
I can tell you right now I never asked
anyone to get an abortion I never paid
for an abortion they think they can
threaten me they think they can scare me
right now that all that done is energize
me more that I'm going to fight and win
this seat for the great people of
Georgia the Trump act nominee and former
football star is taking fire from his
own family Walker son Christian a
right-wing influencer posted I know my
mom and I would really appreciate if my
father Herschel Walker stopped lying and
making a mockery of us
Walker's opponent Senator Rafael Warnock
hasn't weighed in on this controversy
yet but in a sign of how competitive
this race is new fundraising numbers
show that he raised more than 26 million
dollars in the last three months
Walker's Camp has yet to report its
latest numbers Tony
Nicole thank you very much